what we really need to do as a society
is invest in a series of activities and
and areas that we've been neglecting the
average American is working longer hours
today than he or she has you know at
anytime since you know many many for
many many decades what this means is
that as we have sort of over invested in
money and consumer goods and so forth
we've let other sources of wealth erode
we've neglected our communities our
families and our planet
so austerity is is really not addressing
that issue we've got to actually take
our effort our money and our effort to
investing in the things which we have
eroded because hollowing out our
communities hollowing out our families
along our life's lifestyles and so forth
undermine well-being and they undermine
our ability to actually have a more
plentiful and abundant future one of the
ways to think about it is that from the
ecological point of view it's pretty
clear we need a major shift to a whole
new set of technologies the technologies
of the Industrial Revolution which took
nature as if it were endless and in free
supply and we could pollute the
atmosphere without ever paying attention
to it pollute our rivers cut down all
our trees and so forth our technology
our economic system the way we value
things it's all based on that idea which
is a crazy idea and and the the sort of
the chickens are coming home to roost on
that as we've defiled the climate
rundown our ecosystems and so forth to
get to a new kind of production and
consumption system which actually
respects and restores the earth it means
we're going to have to do a lot of
investing but that's investing at a
local scale at a smaller scale it's a
whole different economic
than the one we've been using
we've got 26 million people who are
unemployed underemployed marginally
attached in the labor force we'd have to
be generating half a million jobs a
month for almost two years just to get
back to where we were before the crash
that's a level of job creation that is
absolutely unrealistic and the current
discourse about how to get there is is
woefully inadequate the current
discourse is saying number one cut the
deficit which will further undermine
demand and job growth plus its view is
well let's just try and get the economy
growing and the jobs will somehow
trickle down to the people who need them
that's not the way that mass
unemployment which is what we've got
today has ever been solved and to add to
that there's a dimension of this that
hasn't been recognized in the
conversation that this country is having
which is that we have created a powerful
barrier to job creation in the way we've
structured hours of work for about 75
almost a hundred years beginning in the
late 19th century the country took a
significant portion of its economic
progress of its productivity in the form
of shorter hours of work so it grew it
had increasing income but also workers
got shorter schedules we got Saturday's
off we got eventually you know move down
to something like an eight-hour workday
the concept of a 40-hour week now that's
a completely normal thing to happen and
all of the wealthy countries went on
this path we would never have been able
to reabsorb all the labor that gets
displaced in the ordinary operation of a
capitalist economy if we hadn't done
that because productivity growth is
always generating a reduced demand for
labor we have industrial restructuring
that's going on all the time some
products get popular others decline so
we've we've got to have a way of
reabsorbing the people who are laid off
in the normal course of a market economy
if you don't have reductions in hours
it's it's almost impossible to keep your
population fully employed which means
that when we try and create a job in
this country we've got to generate
somewhere between sort of 10 and 20
percent more revenue and sales for every
job than the European countries have to
so it's a it's a real barrier to job
creation if we had shorter hours of work
if we were able to take productivity
growth over time in the form of shorter
hours we could reemployed us 26 million
under and unemployed people much more
rapidly
for individuals who want to really
secure their economic futures I think
one of the most important principles
going forward is going to be
diversification diversification of your
income sources of how you meet your
daily needs and diversification in terms
of where you invest and this gets us
back to that principle of how what is
wealth and a broader notion of wealth
which includes wealth in the planet it
includes money wealth of course but also
wealth in people if we invest in
relationships with other people that
that becomes a source of wealth so this
brings us back to the question of time
use if people are able to work fewer
hours in the labor market it means they
can take that freed up time and begin
meeting needs in new ways which reduce
their necessity to depend on that market
that market which is going to be less
stable and less lucrative so for example
in the book I look at people who are
involved in a variety of things called
high tech self providing but basically
making and doing for themselves outside
a formal market structure they might be
growing vegetables they might be raising
chickens they may be generating
electricity on a small scale off the
grid they may have solar solar
collectors on their roof or a backyard
windmill they may be involved in sharing
scheme so they don't have to lay out as
much money to get a appliances or cars
or other forms of transports because
they may be sharing with their neighbors
and creating economic interdependencies
that are going to serve them well when
times are a little bit Rocky
in the book I have some pretty
astounding new numbers on what I call
the fast fashion cycle the way in which
consumers have increased the rate at
which they acquire new Goods and then
discard them and that of course was a
predictable result of an economy of lots
of cheap imports artificially cheap
energy again and that that's something
which that's a that's a lifestyle that
in some ways that's a lifestyle that
really has been stopped dead in its
tracks since the recession and many
people have sort of permanently changed
the way they think about consuming as a
result of having gone bankrupt or you
know racked up large credit card debts
that they now are not sure they're going
to be able to pay off their homes had
the trauma of unemployment all of those
things have had a profound impact on a
big swath of the American public who are
now much more interested in saving than
they then spending for the first time
and I really have made changes in their
consumer patterns that look like they're
going to stick at least for a while if
we think about how you can have a
satisfying consumer life in this new
world there are two things that really
stand out one is if you're going to buy
something by for durability both because
it's psychologically much better but
also because in the long run it will
probably cost you less if you can buy
something and keep it for a long time
the second is that we're going to see a
switch from such a heavy emphasis on
buying new to much more of a balance
between buying things new and buying
them used and that this is this is a
trend that's that actually started of
course before the recession in part
because people were buying so many
things there's there's so much use stuff
around what
we're talking about clothes or furniture
or electronics pretty much you name it
in the consumer goods area there there
are growing inventories of used Goods
which the original purchasers don't want
and now we have lots of ways of
exchanging those amongst or among
ourselves whether it's ebay or
craigslist or free cycle or swap meets
or share this stuff a whole range of
specialized websites that allow people
to get rid of things they don't want and
other people to acquire them and then
all the face-to-face places in which we
do this too so the sort of economies of
reuse and exchange are growing rapidly
and I think will become a more permanent
feature of our consumer environment and
that means if you love to shop you can
do it without you know putting too much
pressure on your pocketbook or on the
planet if you love to buy stuff and get
rid of it you can do it then the key
thing really from a financial and
ecological point of view is how much
knew how much how many new consumer
goods Dubai if we if we shift the
balance there because of course the use
stuff is so much less expensive we can I
think you know accommodate both the you
know shopaholics as well as the planet
and our pocketbooks